oh God
oh God
I've never seen a video of this before
this would totally be the part where
your nana would lean over and put her
hand over your eyes
hello I'm Dr Ann Jones the ABC science
nature nerd and today we are going to be
cracking open the bedroom door to peek
inside and see what animals get up to
after dark
[Music]
from brutal displays of dominance to
Grand and sometimes gross romantic
gestures
we have scoured the internet to look for
the five most interesting mating rituals
that the animal kingdom has to offer
[Music]
hello this is Dr Ann Jones here from the
future just to give you a warning we're
about to get sex rated all right play
the clip
it's funny
[Music]
you tend to think of giraffes as gentle
and docile but is there anything about
their behaviors that might change that
what about their sexual behaviors are
they as unique as the giraffes
themselves
oh
we've got giraffe wee okay oh the face
oh he's done the face I love the face
what you're seeing before you is a
giraffe Love Story in real time because
one way to ask a girl out on a date when
your giraffe is by putting your nostrils
into where we
what you want to do is have a bit of a
taste have a bit of a smell and he has
this flemen response where his lip curls
up and he sort of like looks like he's
Frozen in ecstasy for a moment and what
it actually is is an anatomical response
drawing all of the odors right back up
into the nose into the nasal passages so
he can sense whether the female is in
yeastrous and ready to mate
[Music]
oh
and that's what happens when a female
isn't ready to be mounted he'll follow
her around for like hours sometimes just
consistently trying to give her messages
that he wants to make by tapping her
back legs with his front legs and he'll
even sit his head on her rump and around
her rear end it's like the giraffe
equivalent of Tinder she swiped left if
there's one thing that you want your
early love Endeavors to not be it's feel
killed
so yeah this poor guy I mean he had a go
didn't he yeah it's a bit rough laughing
at him she says laughing at him
oh oh
I mean it looks like they're having a
fight with pool noodles right but it's
way more violent than that
they can actually use those Osso cones
those sort of horny Parts on the top of
them as weapons to harm each other so
these two males are having a bit of a
next sword fight because there's
probably a female nearby and when it
comes to mating there can only be one
man who Reigns Supreme at one moment and
that's what they're fighting for only
one of them gets the girl
they sort of act more like chains than
swords because they're bendy and it's
got a whip sort of reaction to it yeah I
mean that just hurt my neck just doing
that and I don't even have a giraffe
neck
oh oh
she's saying hello
God look how much bigger he is
so a male giraffe is significantly
bigger than a female he can be 1.5 times
her entire weight so when they actually
Mount it's actually a pretty short act
in fact even with all the Preamble it
comes up and it builds to a sexual act
of a matter of seconds I mean he's
vigorously trying to mount her so
vigorously that he's Disturbed the
Picker bird
but it's sitting on his head while he's
trying to have sex
it's just weird
oh he's got really bad aim
[Laughter]
I suppose he can't see what he's doing
that was closer so she looks like she's
into it she's not running away she's
sort of presenting she's moving her tail
aside a little bit and he's into it
because he's got a massive erection
and uh that's a love story right there
that is scary
I have 2 000 kilograms of animal just
coming at you
I think it's because of the scale of him
that he looks as if he's running in slow
motion but he's not he's running quite
quickly and in fact they can run up to
60 kilometers an hour which is really
very fast so this giraffe doesn't look
like he's very happy one of the likely
explanations is that there is a female
around that he doesn't want anyone else
near she's almost ready to mate and he's
going to guard her
giraffes really are incredible creatures
it's like a kid drew them I don't know
how they actually exist and they are
incredibly docile in most circumstances
but when it comes to sexy times and also
when they've got children around they
can really mean business
spiders are exceptional Predators if
you're an insect and you come across a
spider you're a Ghana right could it be
that when it comes to mating spiders are
just as dangerous to each other as they
are to their prey foreign
[Music]
he died doing what he loved
spider sex involves the males charging
their Petty pelps which are two really
cute little army things that are at the
front of their sort of mouth area and
basically they jerk off into these
little hands then they approach the
female and in this case he's like
holding her big fangs up away from his
body so that he doesn't die and
thrusting the petty pulps into her one
of the advantages of petty pelps when
you're trying to mate with a massive
alien with huge fangs is that it
provides you a little bit of distance
you can do all of the sex at arm's
length and that's good because when the
fangs come down that is likely going to
be a fatal strike
redback nails are way smaller than
females they're in fact the size of a
perfect prey item for a female so to
give her warning that he's on his way as
a Suitor rather than Uber Eats deliverer
he is plucking her strings gotta have
this nice quiet environment and it's
like he lights a couple of candles and
then he plays Like A really lovely
Flamenco tune on her web and basically
these vibrations are telling her that
he's a male and that he's there for sex
God that really shows you the size
difference doesn't it he looks literally
like a tick on her side rather than a
male
spiders and red back spiders are a
fantastic example of sexual dimorphism
it's where in this case the male and the
female almost look like different
species redbacks are one of the only
species that do this it's called
complicit cannibalism he does like a
forward somersault where he flips his
butt up into the air and then over
directly onto her mouth Parts what he's
actually trying to do is say eat my butt
literally eat me the mother of your
children is gonna need food to make
really lovely strong eggs so you
sacrifice yourself
[Music]
ah
so this is a nursery web spider and I
think the male is doing a little bit of
bondage
some spiders to avoid getting eaten will
actually try and tie little web knots
around the ends of the legs of the
female they'll incapacitate her while
they put their Petty pulps inside
it's kinky stuff
what is it doing
is this oral sex
you might think that
this sort of thing wouldn't be allowed
on the ABC but you would be wrong
all right spider oral sex
who's in
this guy
so this is a madagascan bark spider
they've got quite the sexual repertoire
he does this during copulation before it
after it up to 100 times
[Music]
when it's just not doing it for you you
should be able to make like a high speed
getaway like an ejector seat
and just blast off into space yeah so
that is a method that male spiders use
to protect themselves from being eaten
they basically tense up some of their
legs against the female then as soon as
their pity pulps are in and they've been
successful they just like pulling out of
there and just spraying off at like the
speed of light
which is really fast when you're that
big
these ones are peacock spiders the best
Disco dancers in Australia the males are
often brightly colored especially on
this bit at their back they put it up
and they wiggle it about it's all
iridescent and then they wave their arms
like they're at like a concert in the
2000s what they're trying to do is show
the female how much of a good mate they
would be and I mean it must work she
must like it because if he's successful
and he gets to mate most often peacock
male spiders they actually get to
survive
foreign
cannibalism to dancing from catapulting
to bondage I mean spider sex is a real
mixed bag and it's Risky Business
could end up dying but at least you go
out doing what you love
[Music]
echidnas aren't aggressive but they do
have an excellent form of Defense which
is all of their cool spikes but when you
are a walking ball of needles how do you
actually get your groove on if you know
what I'm saying sounds like it could be
a bit dangerous
[Music]
well here we've got an Australian
Echidna the only one of two mammals in
the world will lay eggs God it's so cute
what a weird animal
they are a special mammal they're a
monotreme and they
do produce an egg the other one what
lays eggs is the Platypus
they're having a good feed
so they've used their claws to rip holes
and then they're long and sticky skinny
tongue goes in and out really really
quickly and that's how they actually
draw all of the ants and termites back
into their mouth
and he's big is extremely sensitive it
has Electro receptors in it so as it is
going along it is sensing the electro
pulses of the muscles inside the
invertebrates that it's searching for
look at these spurs one of the ways oh
look at the little is that is that the
little spur
oh it's much smaller than I thought
so echidnas are monomorphic that means
that from the outside it's really hard
to tell whether they're male or female
because they don't have any external
genitalia Right male echidnas do have a
Spur at the back and it's sort of like
the Platypus spur except echidnas aren't
venomous they're much more likely to
kill you with cuteness
oh God oh God oh oh god oh he's swabbing
it oh for crying out loud
[Music]
let's have four heads on their penis
and they can shoot sperm out of two
heads at once one side or the other
inside the female Echidna in her
reproductive system there's actually
like sort of like a y shape there's two
pockets so maybe it's sort of like this
Evolution that's happened over time
where they go poo and go off to the left
and then in the next time they go and go
off to the right the whole thing is
super weird but that's what you would
expect from an egg laying mammal
so Echidna mating trains I have never
seen one in real life but I've seen lots
of videos like this which basically show
a female being trailed by a big group of
males there's even reports of there
being up to 11 male suitors following
one female this is a mature female and
she's wafting sexy scents all over the
landscape as she's going along can't
help it she just smells sexy and as she
goes all of the male echidnas are
putting their little beaks up and going
I want a bit of that but because
echidnas are essentially extremely
polite animals they just form a line and
follow her around until eventually she's
ready to mate
[Music]
oh
this would totally be the part where
your nana would lean over and put her
hand over your eyes
after the train goes on for a very long
time and the female is ready to mate She
lays down nice and flat on the ground
and then it's sort of like a bit of a
fight for who dares wins you know it
might be the strongest male the quickest
male the last male standing gets to go
in and what he actually does is digs
down beside her and forms a little
Hollow and then he moves his rear end in
underneath and they mate like this so
he's sort of around the side of her and
that's how he avoids getting spiked
I feel like I need to invert my eyes I
mean who filmed this and then what's
that third Echidna doing is he just like
just watching
echidnas are one of Australia's cutest
and most beloved creatures but they are
weird and it's safe to say that they're
sex lives do not buck that trend
[Music]
dolphins are renowned for their
intelligence so does that mean that they
have very intelligent sex
spoiler alert it sort of does but they
also have a dark side
[Music]
oh God why didn't anyone give me any
warning
[Music]
why is that swimmer so close this is all
types of wrong
so yeah dolphin six
often males will actually form little
Cooperative groups in which they sort of
kidnap females until she becomes
receptive to their advances and they can
be quite forceful in that activity that
is a pretty amazing video because you
can see a dolphin penis
Dolphins don't have a breeding season
they breed basically all year and a
dolphin erection can happen basically
instantaneously because sex when it
happens for dolphins is very quick like
seconds long so he needs to be ready
when the opportunity arises do those
swimmers realize what their witnessing
oh amazing we went out snorkeling and
the Dolphins were just playing they were
masturbating foreign
s are smart and will have sex for other
reasons apart from procreation and there
certainly seems to be some behaviors in
Dolphins around the world which indicate
that they
do things for pleasure and this could be
one of them it looks as if they're doing
a nice bit of a wriggle on something
that feels nice on their nether regions
down there
okay it appears to have a sea sponge
that it looks like it's carrying along
so I think what could be happening here
is gift giving the male has a sea sponge
now he's probably ripped that off the
ocean floor and you have to be big and
strong to do that sexy isn't it but also
when you show how big and strong you are
to someone that you're trying to mate
with it could also be an act of
aggression so he's saying I'm big and
strong so you better mate with me
oh wow so we've got some belly to belly
copulation going on how romantic now
they're getting their neighbors involved
oh wow oh God it's a swingers party each
species has their preferred positioning
these are spinner dolphins and their
preferred mating position is belly to
belly as they go along
oh I've never seen a video of this
before
[Music]
it is
dolphin females give birth in shallow
water where it's sort of nice and warm
and they'll often be accompanied by
other female dolphins who act as
midwives so if the mother exhausts
herself during the birthing process The
Midwives can actually scoop up the baby
and lift it to the surface so that it
can breathe there are humans in there
which indicates to me that this is
probably in an enclosure that they're
not wild dolphins keeping in mind that
putting a dolphin in a pen even if it is
on the ocean side is something like 200
000 times smaller than its range in the
wild and it's really bad for their
physical and mental health
yeah
yeah okay so the dolphin is harassing
a human
this is the moment I was waiting for
dolphins are incredibly social creatures
and when they find themselves on the
outer edges of dolphin society that can
be for a number of reasons it may be
because they're not quite right to fit
in with Society it may be that they're
in a pen but it can lead to all sorts of
funny things like dolphins fixating on
humans as objects for sexual
gratification
this is actually a really dangerous
position for these humans to be in
sexual behavior is interlinked with
aggressive behavior in dolphins and I
actually spoke with a wildlife
photographer called Michael who had it
happen to him basically I spent a lot of
time on the Arctic in the water with
whales sharks Dolphins so I look around
and he was literally hanging
hanging next to me less than an arms
length with his eye looking into my eye
but then he started literally charging
us
and I also felt one of my ankles was
being restrained which I just couldn't
figure out what's happening something is
bullying my leg it was very tight hard
to get away from
it's only at home when I also loaded the
videos that I saw like oh yep that was
it
if he says no you can't descend he it's
just a must on top of you and it's
blocking you
if you could go up a little bit it would
just pull you down again
near the end it was getting nasty the
problem here is not the dolphin because
that's just one of the
quadrillion whatever animals in the
ocean the problem is the interaction
with humans or humans interacting with
oh look how cute a dolphin that's the
issue we go into their environment it's
not the other way around it's not our
ocean it's their ocean
yet Michael's experience sounds
absolutely terrifying I mean being
pushed down in the water to the bottom
of the ocean is pretty much the stuff of
nightmares
it's hard to accept that Dolphins aren't
just cute and cuddly when it comes to
their sex life it really is an example
of how they're wild animals and they
really do benefit from being in the open
ocean being wild and free without human
interference and I have to say that this
is one case where I'll happily be in the
friend zone
fascinating amphibians or harmful pests
frogs and toads have a bit of a mixed
reputation and that extends to their sex
life some of it's really fascinating and
quite ingenious
in some of it's macabre so what are some
of the slimy secrets of amphibian sex
[Music]
feel when they come out of your back
so this is a really interesting Suriname
toad so when this sexy mama has sex with
her Suitor he actually pushes the egg
sort of up onto her spongy fleshed back
and once they're in there the skin
eventually grows over sealing them into
a perfect little chamber and they
develop in there and when the moment is
right they split open the skin it's like
throwing back the hatch of like a
submarine and burst into the water and
like swim off and they are little tiny
dark froglets perfectly formed out of
her back
[Music]
so he's a bullfrog right
so the African bullfrog is a beefy boy
he can get up to like two kilograms of
frog and he does partake in Parental
care that means that when the tadpoles
are in the water he'll actually actively
defend them and I think that's what's
happening in this video he has got his
eyes locked on that human as a potential
predator and he is going for it
[Music]
all right well fighting African
bullfrogs because they've got the yellow
underarms and as a lot of conflicts in
the natural world it's generally about
territory or sex
like a pub rule but over a woman
there might be a female in your puddle
that you are protecting and they won't
hold back these bullfrogs if they win
the fight if they kill their opponent
we'll actually eat each other
yeah
plexus alert which is
a love hug
[Music]
and plexus is what frogs do when they
are mating now in almost all cases frog
egg fertilization occurs outside the
body so the male likes to piggyback onto
the female in some way the female
releases eggs out of her cloaca and they
release in this case into the water in
this long string of slimy sort of stuff
the male is piggybacked on top of her
holding on really tight and he is
releasing sperm at the same time
up all right see you later love bye
we're done here see ya it's just like
you
guys
[Music]
group six isn't all that's cracked up to
be guys so these are UK common toads and
this happens in a lot of different
species of toads they make these mating
balls basically where it's just a
squirming mess of testosterone-driven
male toads with probably a female toad
at the middle and they wrestle and mate
for like two days on end
this can and often does result in
female-toed death because she just gets
drowned but also other male toads if
they're on the middle part close to the
female they can just drown as well
frog calls almost universally it's
always males and they are calling for
sex I want it come get it but yelling
out sex sex sex at the top of your lungs
is apparently quite good at getting sex
it also lets all the Predators know
where you are so there is some potential
danger for the males in moaning at the
top of their lungs like this
[Music]
oh they're making a nest so there's so
many ways that frogs care for their
young and some make these amazing
hanging nests for their eggs so what's
actually happening is the female is
excreting a sort of mucus from her
cloaca and what it does is creates a
little bubble holder for all the eggs
and the semen to roll into so what she's
doing is frothing it with her back legs
making sure that her eggs have lots of
moisture because frog eggs are soft
shelled and they need to be hydrated
they don't like drying out that means
they become unviable
however you feel about frogs and toads I
think we can agree that they've got
ingenious mating methods and some pretty
good ways of bringing up their young
they are perfectly adapted to their
environment wherever they are in the
world
there is no denying that these five
animals have some bizarre approaches to
mating
these may be terrifying or kind of gross
to us but when you think about it it's
pretty incredible the links that these
animals will go to just to ensure that
their species lives on
if you like this video and you want to
find out more amazing animal facts then
you should find my podcast It's weekly
and it's called what the duck yes you
can find it on the ABC listen app and
also anywhere that you find your
podcasts